hello everyone this game was a
suggestion from a subscriber this is
game 11 of the Fischer Spassky 1972
World Championship match and I think the
title of the video is failing the crime
and punishment punishment as well Fisher
does commit a crime and Spassky does
execute the punishment but you'll see
what I mean and well Fischer's main idea
for this world championship was not to
play any openings that Soviets had
prepared for so this is a game 11
Fischer went for the poisoned pawn
variation and well this is the second
time he went for it they also played
this variation in Game seven of their
match and Fischer repeated the moves in
game 11 he probably had press ahead on
preparation well an improvement on Game
seven of his own
it's just that spassky's improvement
came a much sooner than Fischer's
improvement so let's see the game
spassky's white and Fisher is black we
have E 4 C 5 so the Sicilian Knight to
f3 d6 d4 C capture Sun before Knight
captures on d4 and Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and now a6 denied or variation
Bishop to g5 e 6f 4 and now Queen to b6
the poisoned pawn variation inviting
Spassky to go for Queen to d2 and give
up the B to pawn so Spassky does he
plays Queen to d2 and Fischer captures
it Queen captures on b2 and we have a
nice 2 B 3 good ideas of trapping the
Queen Fischer goes into a three and in
this position
Spassky played Bishop captures on f6 and
this is where as Pascal deviates from
game 7 in game 7 he went for Bishop to
d3 and the game continued Bishop to e7
Spassky castled and the Fischer had this
freeing resource with h6 Bishop to h4
and Knight captures on e4
Spassky played Knight captures on e4 and
we had Bishop captures on h4 so Fischer
is up to pawns and well after move like
f5 spastically got a very ferocious
attack for the price of two pawns but in
the end the game ended in a draw I will
put a link in the in the description to
this game if you want to check it out
so this
in game 11 after Queen to a3 is passkey
it doesn't allow Fischer to go for this
and play place Bishop captures on f6g
captures on f6 and now Bishop to e2
Spassky is preparing Bishop to h5 if
Fischer allows it but of course Fisher
doesn't h5 is played Spassky castles and
Knight to c6 Spassky plays King to h1 I
useful move getting added well for any
future checks on this diagonal and also
if rook to g8 then rook to d1 will be an
available resource Fischer goes Bishop
to d7 and this is move 14 here Spassky
plays Knight the b1 and this is an
extremely strong move as it prepares a
very devious trap
Spassky said that he found this night to
be one move over the board but everybody
else figured that the Soviets just found
this improvement after thoroughly
analyzing Game seven but Spassky did
spent 20 minutes on this move 14 so you
know you can't really prove or disprove
that he did did or did not find this
move over the board if he says he did I
believe the guy so okay
Queen to b4 Fischer offers to exchange
Queens and Spassky goes Queen to e3 and
this is a very devious move as well what
does Fischer play here well he does have
to develop his King is still in the
center and well although an enjoyable
move would be for example Bishop to h6
but this would actually be a deadly
mistake as now it's possible to play a
three and there's no place the Queen can
go after Queen to a4 Knight to c3 and
the Queen is trapped so this is very
very important for Fischer
so after this a three moves Paschal
would have to play some Fischer would
have to play something like Bishop sorry
after this a three move Fischer would
have to play something like Bishop
captures on f4 and well after Spassky
captures that Queen captures an f4 now
Fisher is and spassky's in protecting b6
Fischer could play Queen to b6 and this
would result in Spassky being
upper piece and this is completely
winning so after this
quinta III move sorry Quinn to a tree
move Queen to III move as a Fisher saw
that his Queen would be trapped
he played d5 maybe maybe a better yeah
maybe a better approach would be first
Knight to e7 and then b5 but this is how
Fischer decided to do it as if he plays
Knight to e7 then a 3/3 he can go Queen
a4 and then Queen to c6 to protect his
Queen but okay Fisher went for d4 d5 we
have a capture Sun d5 and now Knight to
e7 and what do you play here as possibly
well you don't really want to capture
this point if D captures on e6 then f
captures an e6 and this is perfectly
okay for Fisher Fisher might be even
better here so after Knight to e7 is
passed we went for c4
we have Knight to f5 attacking spassky's
Queen Queen to b3 is played h4 and now
Bishop to g4 attacking the knight
threatening to triple Fischer spawns
official plays Knight to d6 not allowing
it and we have a knight 1 to D to fish
replace f5 and now well this f5 is
definitely an idea gone wrong official
plays f5 attacking spassky's Bishop on
g4 and Spassky plays now a three
attacking Fisher's Queen and before
Fischer plays Queen to b6 and now it's
possibly pushes c5 attacking both of the
Queen and the night and d6 we have Queen
to b5 offering to exchange Queens but
here at Spassky plays Queen to c3 and
now well this night is still attacked on
d6 and well here's here's where Fischer
goes for it
he plays F captures and g4 and we have
CA for now and now a Fisher's queen is
definitely trapped and it might be that
this is well some moves at Fischer
missed but it might be that he was
actually going for this Queen sacrifice
so Fisher plays h3 Spassky of course
captures the Queen a capture some b5
and we have h captures and g2 with check
King character son g2 and rook to h3
now attacking the Queen and the first
time I saw this game I thought okay this
is definitely some brilliant attack by
Fisher you know he has this nice rockin
h3 probably moves like Knight f5 to e3
check are coming and probably something
well maybe a queenside castle and then
after this utter rock joins the attack
this will be overwhelming but it wasn't
really like that Spassky played Queen to
f6 as Fisher's night is still attacked
he plays Knight to f5 threatening night
to e3 check but Spassky disregards this
he plays c6 attacking Fischer's Bishop
and e7 and Fischer played Bishop to c8
you don't really achieve anything by
going 493 check because after King to g1
you can't really capture the rook as you
will lose both this Bishop would check
and this night so this is losing
material and the Fischer is already down
material and while after c6 he went
Bishop to c8 we have D captures any 6 F
captures on e6 and rook F to e 1 and
this King in the center of the board is
well it's too hard to play this Fischer
played Bishop to e7 attacking expose his
Queen on f6 and Spassky just played rook
captures on e6 and in this position
Bobby Fischer resigned the game so
although it was a pretty convincing
victory in the match this game 11
definitely went to Spassky well Fischer
doesn't really have anything to do here
if you capture the rook Bishop captures
only six you get Queen captures any six
threatening well everything this Knight
and f5 and if you play something like 93
check King to g1 what do you play here
if you capture
Queen captures you lose a rook and well
that is just too too unpleasant of a
position to play so after this rook
captures on e6
whereas the rook captures an e6 sorry
after rook captures an e6 Fischer
resigned the game so yeah that's game 11
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I would like to thank mano a balla
Subramani and fate boosts the video
services for a contribution to my
channel thank a lot to really appreciate
it and yeah thank you all for watching I
will see you soon guys